did you name your uh your aquarium place
after like punching too I don't know if
I should have lights out aquariums all
right shook it kill him kill them
Aquarium
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
where today we have Mr Ron skulls
we're just talking about uh this amazing
situation where you have a tow company
so no matter where you are in America
you can get and request your car to be
towed back to his
if it's covered technically you can if
it's covered but you know what's crazier
is this [__] is fighting for a
world title next week no no that's a
towing dude
so when there's like oil stains on the
driveway how hard is it to remove it
very hard you have to soak it up in sand
actually it's a legitimate question yeah
you have to soak it up with Santa or you
can actually use kitty litter which is a
hacks you don't have to spend as much
money kitty litter better than Santa
costs more money uh so yeah well there's
absorbent that they make that's
specifically for oil spills but it costs
a lot of money so instead we buy kitty
litter at the pet store it's way cheaper
and then it soaks up oil if you do it
fast enough but if you wait too long it
stains so you got to pressure wash it
and you gotta polish it and grind it but
when that happens usually the person
that's getting towed will file a claim
because you ruined their driveway from
Towing it
oh you know what's crazy though I heard
you have a title fight next week no
what's another boring topic you could
talk about that to avoid that that whole
yeah let's skirt around it a little we
don't like talking about fights or
anything I mean what's your kitty litter
preference
top five top five top five I mean
Kirkland is definitely the number one oh
they're so good
would you call that one The Knockout oh
it's knockout serious and delivery and
all that [__] did you name your uh your
aquarium place after like punching too I
don't know if I should have lights out
aquariums all right sugar kill them kill
them Aquarium
[Laughter]
oh [__] all the fish are dead in there
okay
[__] down no biggie no we ended up
calling a normal name it's called The
Reef The Reef oh that's a cool name it's
cool it's not taken the only other
little brief yeah the killer Reef that's
not called the refs Reef we're the
referee oh
what title are you fighting for next
week no back to the fish oh yeah oh yeah
what else do we got back to the referee
oh dude I want to hear about the fight
favorite fish classic favorite fish
arowana oh wow love me in arowana what
made you want to open that place up
anyway you have like a passion for food
um I mean I I raised fish since I was a
kid my dad got this like 30 000 arowana
when I was a kid 30 000 yes 30 000 is
called a red tail golden it was super
illegal and rare which I don't have
anymore that was like from Asia huh yeah
came straight from Asia Asia how to
taste
I don't know by the time he uh died he
was just covered in mold and he had ick
and all that whoa not good yeah I saw a
30 000 fish die right before my eyes it
was the saddest thing ever how big was
it um it was like this big it was huge
how big was your tank that you added
here like this big yeah he was just
stationary he's like a he's like a wagu
cow it was like a freak accident type
death no my grandma killed him uh yeah
like Vengeance or like no just being a
just an Asian grandma Yeah like you know
it's like hey take care of it like this
and this is what's supposed to eat okay
no problem here's here's something else
yeah it's like please don't give my kid
candy here's all the candy in the world
yes I went to Asia for like four or five
weeks and then I told my grandma feed
them the meal worms feed them the mice
don't feed them any goldfish eats mice
oh dude they're hardcore man they'll
freaking come out just like the mice are
drowning right and they're suffering
whatnot and then
it ends are suffering really quick it
just like swallows them whole it's
always just nicer when Ron says it
though they're so hardcore so you buy
the mice from like what like a Petco or
PetSmart yeah yeah and then do you have
to like whack them first no you just
drop them in and then they fight for
their life and they're like blind
they're like babies so they got like red
eyes oh they're blind yeah
so they only smell fear and they don't
see it
I mean when they're when they're when
they're Neck Deep in water I'm pretty
sure they know they're dying would a
fish like that be worth even more today
uh probably more since it's probably
more legal oh it's more illegal now yeah
they're like super like rare endangered
which I don't have
and you can't get at The Reef dirty
[__] G's holy [__] yeah it was insane
there's your grandma e30gs Yeah add it
to the tap right she's like sure sure
I'll pay it off one day but I I came
home from Asia and the fish was there
and like I saw ick ick is like this
disease where you have like almost like
mold all over the fish and then the eyes
and stuff it's so sad and the fish
developed a personality you know like I
saw it it saw me like we'd stare at each
other sometimes they let me pet it he's
like help me yeah yeah and then it
looked at me and then finally looked at
me and then just started having seizures
like
oh you saw the actual I saw him die yeah
but you had like
yeah it waited for me to come I'd like
to think that it waited for me to come
home we locked eyes I had a seizure it
folded in half and then it floated to
the surface and then it was just done
and then there's um the Goldfish were
alive
um oh my God what a poetic last moment
my heart was broken and then to make the
story even more strange uh the reason
why I had it was because my dad moved to
Vietnam when I was uh when I was younger
so it was like hey son I'm moving to
Asia I'm not going to see you for a
while
um take care of my illegal things yeah
here's here's my gift to you and as a
kid in middle school I was like I don't
want to take care of this fish I gotta
feed it like every day I gotta change
the water like two three times a week
um
and so your grandma did you a favor I
mean I ended up developing a
relationship with the fish so I was like
oh [__] grandma yeah you know I was
like [__] that's heartbreaking grandma
doesn't know any better you know
Grandma's just
um just killing things yeah just showing
love doing her best yeah showing love
not good enough Nick
you know so she didn't mean she didn't
know that feeding gold tissue my dad
always used to do that [__] too I'm like
so I told my dad I don't give taiku a
chocolate oh yeah and then this
[__] would always like give
tiger chocolate hella chocolate and I
come home and like type this [__]
bouncing off the walls I'm like did you
give him chocolate he's like no
chocolate
it's exact standard though your
grandparents friends whatever so is
there an opening date for The Reef uh
yeah it was like three months ago
um we were I even pitched it too I was
like Grand open oh so it's jumbee
related huh
I'm talking about got pushed back like
six got blocked by like permit things
huh it's not even the premise we just uh
what was it we ended up meeting like 30
Grand in like additional equipment I'm
like dude we already dumped like we
dumped like like 200 Grand into this
project we sold marijuana right there
dude yeah and it needs like lighting and
then you know our uh our partner he's
like really he made this thing look like
a freaking Apple Store Museum like it
does look like really really crazy so he
wants like top dollar everything I'm
like dude we
ran out of money we can't dump any more
money into this
um and then so we had to figure out a
certain thing but we ended up getting
the funding for it and then so now it's
back in
back in Action didn't you say that
something about this place has there's
like a only one in the world or
something there's like something in
there that's super unique oh in the
build oh we have a uh we have this
million dollar fish tank that's in there
what the [__] yeah it's just crazy it's
like 10 000 gallons or something like
that and it's custom made it's just like
one giant like oh it looks it's
beautiful you put like a mermaid in
there how big is 10 000 gallons just for
like it actually doesn't even this is it
like Florida ceiling is that ten
thousand oh it's like
it's like eight or nine feet tall and
then maybe like 20 feet long wow dude
that's freaking big but for like 10 000
gallons you would think would be like a
whole room yeah you think it's like a
swimming pool but it's like the Showcase
20 feet long it is a whole room for some
people
[Laughter]
not that I live in a mansion or anything
uh I live in a condo it fits in my condo
oh it does it fits in like your garage
no like the whole thing like like a
front door to the back door oh the whole
place oh wow I could live in there yeah
I thought you're storing it at your
house
but oh yeah we have this unique thing
where uh we have some we have some
special license thingy where we can put
rare illegal fish in as long as we don't
sell it it's a museum now
um so we're gonna start doing field
trips and kids could come look look
there's only one fish of this in America
like separate tickets to that oh no we
would make it public just as a publicity
you can put a shark fin soup yeah oh
yeah when they die it's like now it is
edible oh there's that one shop in the
OC that does like reptiles and stuff oh
yeah yeah and it's almost like a zoo
because they got like big pythons and
crocodiles and like iguanas and stuff
but it's technically a pet store but I
think people some people go there just
to look at the animals because that's
some crazy [__] yep yep the reptiles do
in Fountain Valley yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is super cool yeah since we since
we only have like 10 minutes left how
seniors fly back doing that oh wonderful
we I'll just tell them earlier before we
started
um we went to uh Carnegie man we went to
our first event outside of California so
we went to Pittsburgh at Carnegie Mellon
University and uh yeah we did a work
shop for the students and the faculty
that's sick didn't you win another award
for seniors fight back we got nominated
but we had to turn it down because
there's a there's a rule you can only
win non-profit of the year once I guess
[Music]
sorry not profit of the Year Jesus
Christ yeah we won that last year but
we're not allowed to uh we're turning
Champs dude wow you can't win the two
years in a row sounds kind of lame
doesn't it I know I'm like really I'm
like okay whatever sorry for being so
good dude you're winning all across the
board nothing but W's bro that's been
really cool and then uh what else did we
do oh we just had a comedy show yes
we've seen it yeah random I'm not funny
at all it's like bloopers like footage
we won another award uh best comedy show
there's a group called crazy vocations
they they ran this Con uh this comedy
show last it was last week
um for us and then all the proceeds were
gonna go to us in the Chinatown service
Community Center oh cool and they had
like 20 comedians should show up away
yeah there's it was a long show it was
like three hours I had to pee in the
middle of it I didn't Eve 20 is a lot
damn then um so how much they raise like
20 bucks no they're like five times that
much
wow before before costs yeah yeah this
is all for a good cause you know yeah um
but it was cool uh
I didn't I didn't do any comedy sets or
anything but oh we did a little panel
they did a bunch of jokes and I've never
I've been to two uh three comedy shows
now I've been to Ali Wong I've been to
this is a short dude Kevin Hart and then
um and then this one and so I've never
really had that much experience
experience experience in comedy so it's
pretty cool to see what local local
comedians
do and say
um so it's pretty funny what else is
going on outside of like fight stuff in
your life fighting stuff uh I brought my
first investment property like two weeks
ago wow right yeah congrats dude we're
at uh in Fountain Valley right across my
toe yard [__] Glory right now bro
yeah we what what is it is it a a
commercial or is it commercial yeah it's
a it's M2 zoning so you can like
manufacture do Automotive in there uh
initially we're gonna buy and occupy it
uh but then after crunching all the
numbers KO can't afford it
so we're gonna we're gonna rent it out
to another company oh so we're gonna
have a competing Tow Company open up
yeah yeah across the street and then
squeeze them
so it'll be really cool but uh it's my
first time taking Hannah then so we're
like I had
you know a thousand dollars like okay
pay someone to do a thousand dollars
like f that you know which money we just
paid I'm Gonna Save a thousand dollars
I'm gonna do it myself and then so
digging I was digging dirt for like four
days and it doesn't seem like that hard
it is the freaking hardest thing I've
ever done in my life F digging dirt like
I would rather why is there so much dirt
to dig it doesn't even seem like that
much it was like a little mound of dirt
and there was like a plant in it and
then as I'm like shoveling it like
wheelbarrows like probably like 50
wheelbarrows worth of dirt I was like we
should have thousand gallons of dirt
yeah I was like should I just paid a
thousand dollars to get this done I'm
like and then I found out there was a
giant tree underneath the dirt and then
so we had to get special equipment to to
break up the tree and remove the tree
and the company that was gonna charge us
a thousand now bumped it up to three
thousand because there's a tree in it
and I'm like okay well now we have no
choice what to do it ourselves oh oh and
so we're digging and digging and digging
finally it's all flat and then we're
laying down cement and then oh so on
that property there's nothing on it at
all oh no there's like a little building
and then like a huge parking space yeah
but there was this mound of dirt with a
big tree it looked like
I don't know if I can see it okay you
guys don't censor it it's a it's not
even a bad word it's a [__] willow oh
you were afraid of that I don't know
from Pocahontas like you know that's not
even racial
that's easy what else you got
I'm at the beef Willow
um by the way Ron used to coach kids
class so he never cusses yeah it feels
awkward he says fudge yeah
like uncomfortable I feel like when when
you do that like it makes me do that too
yeah oh fudge like I'm sweating a little
bit like fighting up [__] [__] [__]
finish it
dope man congrats on that on the
property that's cool and you know just a
heads up like I don't do anything about
myself like the towing the investment
properties even the fighting thing like
I don't do anything about myself so I
don't want to make painted picture like
this is a one-man show like I have a
whole team behind me this one man is
responsible for all of them because you
said that we think that it's all you
know Liar Liar and on top of this you
still have time to get ready for a
[__] fight for World title fight I
know kind of it that's I I never I never
expected that to happen especially since
my life changed so dramatically in the
past two years
um how did that come about like how did
the that opportunity come
um it came about because I won the wbb I
won the WBC title because you won
another title uh two years ago and then
um and you can't win them two years in a
row yeah exactly they make you take it
off and give it back and that one is for
that one's for the that makes me number
one in the U.S in the U.S for for Muay
Thai yeah damn bro that's crazy man
um but this sounds now now embarrassed
but they they couldn't find me a fighter
in America to challenge me for the belt
um because I probably wants to fight you
Ron I fought legit guys in America
um and so that we've been having trouble
finding opponents so like effort you
want to move up a weight class and we'll
offer you the wsk world title and I was
like heck yeah
um
and then so they offered uh
Papaya's brother
um super good dude from a really good
team we ended up fighting him and then
we ended up winning won the wck world
title and then uh now they want me to
defend it
but the guy I was fighting couldn't make
way he told me three weeks in advance
hey I'm not gonna equate do you want to
move up and wait I was like does that
mean it's not a title defense like yeah
it's just an exhibition like dude I'm
freaking 37 years old what am I gonna
fight for fun for you're only fighting
for gold yeah I want to fight for a free
kid either a massive amount of money or
uh
or a title yeah you know and then so
I'll move up to 145 I'll move to 155
it's for a title and they're like oh no
it can't be I was like it doesn't it
doesn't make sense I was like okay well
then find me somebody that can make
weight and so they found me a better
opponent um he's the current wvc
champion for Mexico so I'll be fighting
the number one ranked guy in Mexico
um next week you don't know his name
oh it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
it's Chavez uh something Chavez
good guess I just found out like
Salvador of Alaska Salvador of Alaska oh
my gosh Salvador of Alaska so is this is
this a fight that two seconds
where's the venue can we watch this
fight like is this one that we can go to
yeah it's uh it's next weekend though
the last time Bart came he watched me
die
can we go or what I went to one of his
fights don't win it only time the one
the one only fight that's why he got
knocked out yeah yeah I almost said
threw up like yeah when you watched like
regular people fight there's no
emotional attachment yeah right like Ron
is my coach he's coached me for two
years and he's a personal friend so
there's like an emotional attachment
that I didn't know gives you a very
visceral reaction so Ron was beating the
[__] out of this guy and then um I think
Ron got cocky should put his hands on
coming down and this guy literally just
like ducked his head and just went bam
over the top and not Ron gets knocked
out and I'm like oh he gets knocked out
by the way it was like I couldn't even
control it yeah
that he hit me I whiplashed back and I
just flat back on the ground and
everybody was like uh bro I couldn't
believe it I couldn't believe because I
knew the guy he was gonna fight and I
was telling everybody I was like bro Ron
is gonna destroy this dude he was and he
was and he was but all it takes is one
all it takes is one especially anime he
talked so much crap and he earned it you
know so I just said I was like but run
it back though right for what what but
you don't want it though you probably
wouldn't though no there's no reason
absolutely no reason to say what oh I
got you back yeah yeah yeah you know who
cares
um he earned it he deserves everything
um and everything like that they can
yeah it's not uh that is that racist
what I totally said his name wrong I say
[__] will though nobody yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
just say [__] Travis now I feel awkward
singing the tree so you I would never
say that tree ever again
delete that tree you have a fight next
week on Saturday or Sunday or next
Saturday so I I set my cut today day so
I haven't actually eaten yet I'm fasting
right now
um I do keto and then I'm gonna do water
little gotta cut 15 pounds
that's normal you gotta cut 15 pounds in
one week yes well technically I'm gonna
lose 15 pounds the night before because
I'm gonna be drinking like freaking a
butt ton of water oh um
but like a willow ton
a chunk full let's go to his fight let's
go yeah it'll be fun said El cajon's at
the Sycuan Casino
um like San Diego area and like uh
coincidentally I've become very Middle
Eastern because all a lot of people in
the towing industry in Middle Eastern
um and so in El Cajon there's this
middle eastern restaurant that makes
this like and I didn't know this like
when you go to like Mediterranean
restaurants and Iraqi restaurants and
like and Arabian restaurants they all
seem like they have the same menu like
it's a kebab or Shawarma yeah yeah yeah
they're all completely different yeah
it's I had no idea and so I started
eating Iraqi food and um
there's this place in El Cajon it's one
of my favorite restaurants ever I don't
know the name of it because it's in a
weird writing
um but it's this old family and they
just stand in this oven it would fire it
with metal skewers and they're just
standing there with like this meat
skewers and like liver and all kinds of
weird stuff and uh you bring it out and
just eat it with pita and and tabula and
Tzatziki and all that stuff and hummus
and just eat with your hands and just
and it's like the best meat ever like
the meat is tender it's juicy it's like
a charred crust on the outside and like
all the veggies are fresh the pita has a
slight crisp and it's like fluffy and
steamy yeah it really is or that's how
it is because you've been like water
loading and like not eating I mean I
don't know he's selling it to me though
oh dude I don't work there I'm not
affiliated with them I don't even know
the name of the restaurant he's a true
fighter follow me the food but I don't
know where to get it you can't even
advertise it alcohol and it's in this
like tiny little like one block Iraqi
Chavez
it's in it's called trellis wait can you
briefly explain why the towing business
is mainly uh Middle Easterns I have no
idea on the history of that you know I
assume maybe somebody from the Middle
East came over and they're like let's do
touring so just like Cambodian Donuts
they invited everybody else that you're
towing and then now because now
everybody does Towing but it's pretty
it's predominantly uh Middle Eastern
Mexicans and white people
um barely any Asians like maybe it was
like like in the mother country we still
over here with toe yeah we take we
thought I think we think yeah I went to
uh there's Towing conventions I went to
one yesterday was it yesterday yeah yeah
I went to Vegas yesterday and came back
uh for a towing convention I know I
didn't call you because I was I was here
anyways
no because I would have not had time to
come see anyways yeah I was like uh he's
busy anyways but I went there and it's
literally putting like 90 Middle Eastern
people oh cool who was the musical act
for entertainment
um you know what you would think they
would have entertainment it is they're
none the entertainment oh
[Laughter]
Tony Bennett they're uh their
entertainment is a beauty pageant but
for tow trucks
um so you go and you you you dress the
truck up yeah you're just a checkup oh
that's sick no yeah they're actually
it's crazy dude some of these tow trucks
are like a million dollars dude I
believe it's pretty hardcore they hold
ten thousand how much on average are the
ones that you guys have at Ko mine uh
trucks are about like 100 grand
my Lord and you have how many now uh we
have 10 tow trucks and three service
vehicles
come on baby
oh my God
but keep in mind everybody thinks I'm
balling
ball and is just taking all the money
we've made and just dump it back into
other stuff so I've spread say that to
your Range Rover outside yeah I got that
for a really good deal
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh